all right here with Austin st. John the
original Red Power Ranger from Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers how's it going
awesome it's good man Chicago has been
treating me right that's good place I
love it what is it like to over 20 years
later now since power injures first
debuted and now you're here meeting all
your fans as adults there were kids when
you're watching a show myself included
it what is it like meeting all your fans
you know 20 years ago we got to see
little boys hiding behind mom's leg
little girls hiding behind mom's leg we
knew we had an impact I think what I
love now is they've grown up and now
instead of just knowing the Nielsen's
rate the Nielsen ratings tell us we did
great now they're coming up to my table
and they're sharing their stories so we
didn't just reach a bunch of children
and and their parents back then we reach
deeply because they're coming up and
they're telling me stories that blow my
mind you know some of us were father
figures or brother figures or sister
figures or or you know other other major
important figures to children that
someone didn't have those roles and
those role models and I mean you can't
be human and not have that hit you in a
feelgood's so I just I love it every day
I just I love here and what people have
to say it's amazing
another thing I want to ask about is the
new Power Rangers movie that's coming
out from Lionsgate are you excited for
that slash are you involved in any
capacity I have had discussions I
currently have no contract so no
promises as far as I'm excited for it
the the star of the film reached out to
me on Twitter for some discussions and
hoping that we chat soon
I'm really curious to see what they're
gonna do I really am
so I don't know what to make of it just
yet I can tell you I got some other
projects coming up I'm getting ready to
be part of a whole nother superhero
franchise it's called black salt and
it's based on a comic book series Owen
Ratliff is one of the producers we've
got Sifu Robinson who is one of the
executive producers and tied into it in
martial arts
and I can't say a whole lot more here's
what I can tell you HBO in April there's
a premiere of a short film coming out
they shot that before they found me
because I was I was overseas for the war
and it airs this April on HBO at the
very end after the credits you're gonna
see something with me attached to it
talking about when the full-length
feature comes I'm gonna be there and
we're gonna put it out to the fans and
make it their vote do you want me to be
a bad guy or a good guy so we're gonna
get people involved it's gonna be a lot
of fun I'm so jacked up about it so go
to Facebook Black's all go to the
website black salt calm check it out
lots of good stuff coming man great is
there anywhere online that people can
check you out right now yeah go to
Facebook at Austin st. John you'll see
the blue checkmark there so the page has
been verified I do a lot of my stuff
there Twitter asj Austin Instagram
Austin hash underscore st underscore
John and then I'm building a website
that all advertise across all that
social media right now so I got a lot of
good stuff coming I've got five other
films I'm working on too so good stuff
it's an honor man I'm such a huge fan
since the beginning so thank you so much
for than ever I really appreciate it